what's the point of doing this well what
we're interested in is exploring what
the experience of actually assembling a
robot what the effect that has on your
later experience with the robot
so we have our subjects come in and just
they take around 10 minutes to put
together all of these parts so you know
maybe they feel a bit of a sense of
extension of the self into the robot so
what we do is after subjects build the
robot we take the robot away and say
we're giving them a different one in
some conditions and in other conditions
they actually use the one that they
built the thinking there's that even if
it's the identical robot the exact one
that they built just that experience of
assembling it it's going to result in
kind of an extension of the sense of
self so what's this now we're on to the
second part yeah so now we go to the
second stage so what we do here actually
is we hook you up with the physiological
sensors and then what follows is
basically a game that's kind of similar
to minesweeper so what you're gonna do
is you are going to position your robot
in the center Square and you can point
it in whatever direction you want okay
this is good just being offenders mm-hmm
okay
you can point it in whatever direction
you want and you're gonna aim for the
points that you can see in the squares
around it there you go
looks like you're on a bomb say I'm on a
bomb and then we look at what your
physiological indicators are so we've
done it with self reports which very
consistently showed that if you've built
this robot then you're going to respond
very differently than if you're building
if you're operating the robot that you
actually built but you think somebody
else builds where does this research
lead us it has important implications
for a couple areas of human robot
interaction so one would be
search-and-rescue so in lots of cases
you want people to feel an extension of
themselves into the robots but not in
every case in really high-stakes
situations like search and rescue
operators are under crazy stress trying
to guide this robot through sale a
minefield and in that case we don't want
them to suffer the physiological
consequences of feeling like really like
being scared yeah they don't want to
have this you know this constant feeling
like they themselves are going through a
minefield
so here we are with a Robosapien by
wowie a standard toy that you can get
anywhere pretty much that we have
converted here to use for some studies
we've cut its vocals and stuck a
walkie-talkie on the back so that we can
get sound out of it basically we're
interested in seeing what happens when
you have a robot that needs to disagree
with you in a case like say maybe moon
colonization where a robot is helping
you weld or do something like that and
the robot knows better than you and
wants to disagree you're disagreeing
with a idiom right now basically the
setup that we have here is a desert
survival task it's basically a ranking
of items to see which you wouldn't want
if you were stranded in the desert and
the robot is going to disagree with your
suggestion
so say you say a flashlight is the most
important thing that you would want out
in the desert
this guy disagrees and says that he
actually thinks the pistol is a better
choice so why do we want to know how to
how to make ourselves respond better to
our own robots sure well I mean as
robots are getting more and more capable
they may have information and knowledge
that superior to our own in a case like
that it's pretty offensive for a robot
to disagree with you you can just
imagine your natural response would be
not to accept it exactly so we're trying
to explore ways that you can have that
robot communicate the information
without the person really hating the
robot in this case we actually deal with
the distancing so you know sometimes if
you're criticizing somebody you might
say one might say that this performance
that we've seen is not so great so
you're distancing yourself from the
negative comment here we're actually
physically distancing the voice so in
one condition we have the voice coming
out here but we've also done it where we
have his voice coming from this control
box and what we find is that that
physical distancing of the voice makes
people like the robot more when it's
disagreeing with them I would like to
hear the robot disagree be yeah you
disagree with me let's see so I'm
telling him to go forward
when they me doesn't want a knife could
be helpful and cutting down steaks to
build shelter that is not as good as the
pistol which could be good for signaling
for help which do you choose
and you find that if it comes out of
here e people are more likely to agree
with the Rossum and yeah well we find
that people like the robot more when it
disagrees ok so what do they make the
choice that he recommends more people
make that choice more often when he
disagrees so in the case where the robot
says you know use you first select the
flashlight and he says actually the
pistol is better in that case people are
more likely to change their answer to
the pistol when they have their second
chance to make their priorities then if
the regret the robot had agreed with
their initial choice